[Musique]
nous sommes le 21 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité aujourd'hui
louis burton a bouclé son vendée globe
rencontre sur la terre ferme avec le
navigateur l'yvelinois revient sur son
expérience
pascal granger et directeur général
délégué de bouygues construction nous
sommes allés faire le point sur les
activités du groupe dans les locaux de
challenger le siège à 55 ans ni le
rambolitains louis burton a donc franchi
le jeudi 2 février au matin à 8h47 très
précisément la ligne d'arrivée aux
sables d'olonne il termine à la 7e place
de cette édition du vendée globe le
skipper de bureau vallée a bouclé son
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale pour la première fois en 87 jours
21h45 vitesse moyenne 13 noeuds plus de
trois semaines après son arrivée miquel
et demi d'euros l'a rencontré à paris
sur la terre ferme et au sec
alors je suis avec louis burton le
skipper évinois qui vient de boucler le
vendée globe en 87 jours il est arrivé
le 2 février et il est avec nous ici à
paris parce que voilà les les
l'exposition médiatique s'enchaînent ici
suite à votre exploit comment vous
sentez vous depuis votre arrivée
mais je suis passé un petit peu par tous
les états
je suis arrivé plutôt fatigués mais en
bonne santé et puis j'ai attrapé la
grippe les coups de fatigue récurrent du
mal à trouver le sommeil
à terme et mais plutôt plutôt en forme
on va parler tout d'abord de la course
voilà est-ce que les objectifs ont été
remplis finalement vous nous parliez de
85 jours vous avez fait 87 jours est ce
que les objectifs sont remplis vous avez
fini quand même une très belle septième
place
alors c'est vrai que on avait visé entre
85 et 95 jours il ya eu une descente de
l'atlantique sud très compliqué avec des
passages à niveau les bateaux très
récents sont partis un peu par devant
puis après derrière il a fallu se
bagarrer pour décrocher le peloton faire
un peu une échappée et je me suis
retrouvé à partir de l'indien de l'océan
indien
à la 9e place et puis ça s'est
transformé en septième place dans le
pacifique et ensuite j'ai fait toute la
course un peu cavalier seul toute la fin
de course est arrivé aux sables
oui en 87 jours
à 7e place avec ce bateau d'une dizaine
d'années c'est vraiment dans la partie
haute des objectifs donc on est très
content et et grosvalet a fait vraiment
vraiment une belle course c'est vrai
bien soutenu vrai quel est votre
meilleur souvenir en mer vous en rêvez
forcément ouais alors c'est un souvenir
un peu un peu particulier parce qu'ils
les empreintes de pas mal de craintes et
d'inquiétude c'était le passage du cap
horn
puisque je suis passée auprès donc vent
de face dans une météo très compliqué et
c'est vrai que j'ai eu très peur dans
cette zone là et en revanche quand on en
est sorti et que on est à nouveau
dégager de la terre on met le clignotant
à gauche ont commencé à rentrer vers la
maison voilà ça c'est un souvenir de
joie de fierté de délivrance enfin il ya
vraiment plein de plein de sentiments
mêlés et je crois que ça restera le
vraiment le moment fort mon vendée globe
al'inverse quel est votre pire souvenir
ça a été difficile sur un globe ouais
c'était très difficile
la course en elle-même est très dure a
les plus belles
j'ai trouvé ça beaucoup plus difficile
que ce à quoi je m'attendais par la
longueur en fait de l'effort qu'il faut
fournir ça s'arrête pas et c'est vrai
que les imoca sont des bateaux qui sont
très physique très violent quand ça va
vite et arriver à tenir ces vitesses là
sur ces machines là pendant aussi
longtemps c'est une vraie épreuve
ensuite il ya deux moments
particulièrement douloureux c'est dans
la descente de l'atlantique sud lorsque
la météo s'ouvre pour le groupe de
devant et se referment juste pour moi je
suis le premier qui qui voit la fenêtre
météo se refermer ça c'est un moment qui
psychologiquement a été très compliqué à
gérer
et puis le retour le passage du
pot-au-noir au retour avant le
pot-au-noir en fait on
on arrive à rooter jusqu'à jusqu aux
sables d'olonne à peu près avec des
fichiers à 15 ses jours et voilà c'est
une erreur parce que dans le pot-au-noir
le c'est très difficile d'avoir des
conditions météo des prévisions météo
correcte mais je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher
de faire ça et en fin de compte j'ai
passé trois jours à l'arrêt dans dance
pot-au-noir et je suis arrivé du coup
j'ai à nouveau eu la fenêtre météo qui
s'est fermé et je tablais sur une
arrivée le 27 ou le 28 février et en fin
de compte je suis arrivé le 2 février
donc voilà ça fait c'est lé moment ça
fait très longtemps qu'on est en mer et
on a bien envie d'arriver donc forcément
quand on ralentit par rapport à ses
prévisions basses et de bons coups de
massue sur la tête
alors pendant 87 jours vous avez été à
priver de vos proches vous avez
enregistré de nombreuses vidéos vous
avez parlé vécue par mail est-ce que
c'était important également d'avoir ce
contact avec l'extérieur tout au long de
votre périple
oui alors c'est vrai que pour moi ça
s'est révélé être essentiel parce que en
fait dont le manque c'est une chose mais
on sait finalement on sait à quoi
s'attendre par contre l'inquiétude et
l'angoissé qu'on a pour les gens qu'on
laisse à terre c'était surtout ça qui
qui en fait s'est révélé assez difficile
et assez douloureux maintenant parler du
futur
vous avez racheté donc le bateau par
bureau vallée a racheté le bateau du
vainqueur du vendée globe de cette année
vous quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à par rapport à cet achat vous
êtes j'imagine très enthousiastes et
prêts à le l'exploiter au maximum
oui tout à fait en fait on a on a
travaillé avec dorval et toute l'année
dernière toute l'année 2016 pour
imaginer ce que pourrait être la suite
de notre projet de nos cinq premières
années là en imoca
on a on avait vraiment bien pressenti ce
bateau qui a eu un énorme développement
qui a gagné la transat anglaise qui a
fait deuxième de la jacques vabre
l'année dernière et on voit là on est
très content parce que armel a fait une
course superbe avec le bateau s'est
révélé très performant et et l'équipe de
banque populaire travail là actuellement
avec notre équipe de bureau vallée pour
mettre le bateau à l'eau en mars fin
mars début avril
donc on est très enthousiaste on suit ça
de près il l'a ramené en bon état donc
c'est vraiment de bon augure pour la
suite
merci beaucoup lui burton et à bientôt
pour de nouvelles aventures merci
beaucoup
un tout autre sujet à présent pour
poursuivre ce set 8 invités et le marché
du btp qui se porte plutôt bien à
l'image de l'entreprise bouygues
construction implantée engagés sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
elle la filiale du groupe bouygues est
ça connaît une stabilité dans ces
résultats c'est ce qu'a expliqué pascal
granger est interviewé par nicolas
landry
nous sommes aujourd'hui sur le site
challenger au siège social de bouygues
construction en compagnie de pascal
granger bonjour bonjour monsieur
alors pascal granger je vois je rappelle
que vous êtes directeur général délégué
chez bouygues construction et donc la
construction c'est la filiale du groupe
bouygues spécialisée dans le bâtiment et
des travaux publics
pouvez vous nous expliquer pourquoi
bouygues construction est venu
s'implanter sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
alors c'est une longue histoire en fait
c'est le groupe bouygues qui est venu
s'installer à à challenger à la fin des
années 80 le groupe où ils connaissaient
une très forte croissance et avait
occupé complètement le site précédent
qui était à clamart trois constructions
successives la challenger à était
devenue une nécessité parce que la
croissance nécessitait de nouveaux
espaces et nous avons lu voulu faire à
l'époque un siège emblématique d'accord
alors quels ont été les critères les
facteurs de l'attractivité du territoire
d'une nouvelle donc un signe de bonne
heure 10 mhz
et puis de l'espace vous avez vu nous
sommes sur un site qui fait près de 30
hectares
et puis un réseau de transport très
performant puisque nous avons ici le
train le rer qui permet d'arriver à
différents endroits de paris
et puis pour nos collaborateurs qui
étaient dans la banlieue ouest de paris
c'était aussi plus facile de venir à
challenger alors parlant d'économie
maintenant la situation actuelle du
marché
quelle est-elle sur l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines alors vous
savez nous nous sommes un acteur
français international donc nous
intéressons naturellement au territoire
mais nous couvrons l'intégralité de
l'île de france la france et 80 pays
dans le monde
ce que l'on peut dire en france c'est
que nous avons un marché un peu à deux
vitesses on a une île de france qui est
très dynamique et des régions qui ont
moins d'investissements d'accord et
principalement sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
quels projets sont en cours de
réalisation en cours de réflexion
peut-être alors nous nous sommes un
constructeur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'abord nous
avons construit notre siège mais
maintenant il ya un peu prescription et
nous avons construit le siège de sorts à
et le siège de bouygues énergie et
services australiens
nous avons construit le stade vélodrome
que vous connaissez bien et pour
l'instant si on parle d'actualité
immédiate nous sommes conçu par exemple
en train de construire un ehpad 1 et une
résidence seniors aux manettes
globalement le groupe bouygues de
l'ordre d'un peu plus de 50 mille
collaborateurs sur le site de challenger
nous sommes environ 3500 et nous avons
500 collaborateurs environ à australiens
ont abordé les chiffres notamment les
résultats de 2015 vous avez réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires de 12 milliards
d'euros soit une croissance de 2% en un
an
comment vous analysé ce bilan de 2015 en
2015 c'est un peu loin vous avez vu
probablement vu nos chiffres de
trimestriels qui démontre une stabilité
de notre activité sur l'année 2016
une année de consolidation il faut
savoir qu'il y a dix ans à peine le
chiffre d'affaires de bouygues
construction étaient de moitié inférieur
justement j'avais abordé les chiffres
2016 quelle évolution vous attendez en
chiffre d'affaires stabilité en résultat
des résultats très homogène à ceux de
2004 et quelles sont vos perspectives de
développement pour l'année 2010 est
alors nous avons un marché en france qui
qui est porté et notamment en
ile-de-france à la fois par le projet du
grand paris est à la fois partout le les
efforts que fait l'état français pour le
très haut et le très haut débit
numérique
alors nous avons une tradition chez
bouygues et c'est de continuer à
embaucher même dans les périodes
difficiles et si je devais donner un
exemple je pense que sur les deux années
environ
on sera entre 1500 et 2000 en bouche par
vous embauche avec quel type de contrat
vous savez dans un groupe aussi
diversifiés que le nôtre toute la
palette des contrats étaient utilisés
nous avons évidemment des contrats
d'apprentissage nous avons des stages
nous avons des biens sur des cdd en
grande partie et des contrats à durée de
chantier pour nos chantiers depuis
décembre 2016 le dispositif de la carte
professionnelle du btp est expérimenté
dans certaines régions comment se
déroule la mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif au sein de votre entreprise
alors moi ce que je veux dire c'est que
évidemment nous supportons beaucoup
cette démarche parce que dans notre nos
valeurs il ya deux valeurs qui sont
extrêmement importantes pour nous il ya
la sécurité vous avez probablement vu en
arrivant sur le site un grand calicots
devant le poste de garde qui expliquait
que la sécurité notre était notre
première priorité est évidemment les
tickets là le respect de la
réglementation de travail en est une
autre et nous pensons que c'est un très
bon instrument est évidemment nous
allons déployer aussi vite que possible
concernant ce dispositif qu'est ce que
vous pensez d'efficacité de cette mesure
pour notamment lutter contre le travail
dissimulé la concurrence déloyale c'est
les priorités affichées par
gouvernement il est clair que pour nous
l'enjeu c'est pas le travail dissimulé
c'est l'enjeu c'est d'être sûr ce ne
sont pas les faux papiers sont les les
échanges d'identité et donc tout ce
qu'il ira dans le sens de la
sécurisation de nos collaborateurs et de
leur identité est pour nous une très
bonne chose et la fin du set 8 invités
pour ce soir replay sur notre site
internet nouvelle édition demain aux
horaires habituels très belle soirée
[Musique]